[Musique]
bonjour oui je vous parlais du film le
vent de charlie régis valette voir ce
qui allait du moment du même nom
toujours la nuit par stephen fry
l'histoire chez déroule aux états unis
au début des années 90 on suit
l'histoire de charlie un nouveau jeune
lycéen qui va considérer comme blizzard
par le reste de sa classe sa vie va
changer quand tu vas faire la rencontre
de deux terminales sam et patrick qui
ont fait redécouvrir la vie de lycéens
mais aussi l'amitié le monde des adultes
ou même l'amour le film était un gros
mélange d'émotions parce qu'on peut
aussi bien rire et la minute d'après
être triste chalier dans un souffre
douleur dans son école mais qui peut
être rapproché à ce que nous connaissons
en france par rapport aux autres finales
le n 1 américain qui extrapolent nous
avons aussi le bonheur d'avoir trois
acteurs pour jouer les rôles principaux
qui ne sortent pas une fois leur rôle et
qui du coup ne nous font jamais sortir
du film et je crois que tout cela
ajoutait la mise en scène est jeté à
plein des éléments que je ne peux
divulguer sans raconter tout le film qui
font de ce film l'un de mes films
préférés
et c'est donc pour cela que je ne peux
que vous conseiller de regarder ce film
qui traite de la licence américaine
comme je ne l'avais jamais vue
auparavant merci d'adapter leur donnons
une voir ce film
[Musique]